something is very wrong with our son
it's turned into a spinning Lighthouse
of death
what would make the Sun so much more
deadly than usual
is there any way life on Earth could
survive this
and why would it feel like you're stuck
at the bottom of the ocean
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth was a pulsar planet
many stars go out with a bang
exploding in brilliant supernovas but
our sun has gone straight to becoming a
pulsar
is sometimes called a neutron star you
you could take this as some good news
the sun exploding would obliterate Earth
and take nearly the rest of the solar
system along with it
but now that it's a neutron star the sun
would be among the densest objects in
the universe and one of about 200 000
pulsars in the Milky Way
shrinking itself about 70 000 times the
size it used to be our sun wouldn't be
much bigger than a small City at 10
kilometers across and it would be
spinning very fast
if it's anything like the Pulsar located
in the Virgo constellation it could make
about 161 rotations every second
oh and it would also shoot beams of
deadly radiation directly toward the
Earth every few seconds or even
milliseconds
with all this radiation beaming down you
don't really have much time but you can
still have the time to learn a new
language with speakally you can get from
ground zero to solid speaking skills in
about three to four months all it takes
is about 30 minutes daily and this
awesome mobile app available on Android
and iOS
you know one of the things that stops me
from learning new languages is that most
language apps teach you phrases that
you'll never use and because I have no
use for them I forget everything I
learned quickly but speakly is different
it only teaches you what you need to
know in real life situations you'll
learn how to write read and most
importantly how to speak
speaking has always been the tough one
for me so if you've ever wanted to learn
a new language well here's your chance
click on the link below and start your
free seven-day trial of speakally and
get a 60 discount if you join the annual
subscription if I did and just in time
for my vacation in France
too bad I won't enjoy my new language
for long because the Earth is about to
get fried
okay the first thing you'd notice would
be that things suddenly got a lot darker
our son would emit almost no visible
light
but you'd still be able to catch quick
glimpses of it though only for the
extremely brief moment that its pulse of
energy is directly pointing at us
the sun would now be like a pulsing
Lighthouse at the center of our solar
system
this eternal Darkness would cause a lot
of problems back here on Earth
there would be no more photosynthesis
trees would no longer be able to produce
oxygen and crops wouldn't grow so
animals and humans would be on the brink
of mass starvation
but there would be good news
astronomers have found exoplanets
existing in a pulsar's habitable zone so
maybe just maybe you'd have a chance to
survive this
one especially because the habitable
zone of a pulsar could be nearly as
large as a normal star that would mean
it could still be possible for liquid
water to exist on Earth's surface
but this liquid water would only be able
to exist thanks to our warm atmosphere
trapping energy from the Sun
and while there wouldn't be much visible
light there would be a lot of radiation
that's because neutron stars have
incredibly strong magnetic fields
this would cause beams of X-rays and
gamma rays to shoot out from the sun's
poles
yeah and this would be very bad news
all this radiation would be highly
lethal in order to prevent it from
reaching the Earth's surface our
atmosphere would need to be thicker
maybe as thick as one million times what
it is today
if you managed to pump enough air into
the atmosphere to reach this desired
thickness you'd have to get used to
living with an atmospheric pressure as
intense as the deepest parts of the
ocean
it would be like going down 10
kilometers to the bottom of the Mariana
Trench
but you wouldn't be able to get close to
that depth before you'd be completely
crushed
before you even hit the halfway point
your eardrums would rupture and your
lungs would fill with blood and collapse
but you might not need to worry about
this because Earth wouldn't be able to
hold such a dense atmosphere in place
the Relentless radiation would just
blast it away
and if enough of the atmosphere
disappeared the liquid water on Earth's
surface would eventually boil away
and that would be the guaranteed demise
of human life on this once habitable
Space Rock
which makes me think
What would happen if the oceans simply
boiled away
full health that sounds like a story
for another
what if
foreign